avec plus de 12 millions de baril de
pétrole extrait par jour dont 7 millions
de pétrole de schiste les etats unis se
taillent la part du lion dans la
production de l'énergie fossile
à tel point que selon lagence mondial de
l'énergie dans la période 2010 9 2024
ils représenteront un seul 70% de la
croissance de la production mondiale
leur permettant de passer devant la
russie d'ici 2023 et de se passait pas
très loin derrière le premier producteur
d'or noir
l'arabie saoudite alors les états unis
pourront-ils célébrer leur indépendance
énergétique buste et leur et que 2000
avec leur pétrole de schiste et bien
tout n'est pas si simple
le pétrole de schiste est beaucoup moins
lourd que les pétroles plus
conventionnels comme celui par exemple
provenant du venezuela
et malheureusement pour les américains
leur raffinerie ne sont pas du tout
adaptés à traiter ce type de pétrole
très léger donc mais plutôt à
transformer du brut lourd depuis le
lancement de l'extraction massive de
schiste les raffineries n'ont pas encore
pu s'adapter correctement vu les énormes
investissements que cela demande
exxon première compagnie pétrolière
privée au monde a par exemple mis 9
milliards sur la table dans l'urgence et
pour le moment pour traiter ce fameux
pétrole léger
ils doivent le mélanger avec du plus
lourd qui vient d'autres pays
une situation qui pourrait malgré tout à
terme se régler et permettre aux états
unis de se passer de leurs douars les
autres l'avenir le dira mais en
attendant la cour bulle des importations
de pétrole aux états unis est en forte
chute
concept de la production ne fait
qu'augmenter depuis 2010
[Musique]